subaru of las vegas the sponsors of this
next segment has a car and accessories
to fit every season take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
eric what time is your delivery today
hey hey how's it going buddy how are you
good
to see you my man what are you doing i
am ready to go on a vacation school's
out summer's here i'm ready for a road
trip and i figured you guys would have
the perfect car we do have the perfect
car the 2022 subaru ascent show me okay
come on let's go i'll grab your luggage
that is customer service right there
thank you with a smile
burton i have to tell you this is big
and this is bold tell me more the 2022
subaru ascent it's motor trend's
absolutely number one three-row suv
symmetrical all-wheel drive turbo
charged engine and iihs top safety pick
plus so you save you've got the power
you can go anywhere and it even hauls a
lot of luggage my god this is heavy what
do you have in here hair product
i believe it can i see the inside of it
yeah
jc we're talking about a road trip i've
got to mention the subaru eyesight
accident avoidance system it's amazing
automatic emergency braking it lane keep
assist and it has that adaptive cruise
control which will help you maintain a
distance from the car in front of you
it's amazing oh i have to mention the
system here to keep everybody
entertained it's amazing
subaru you guys the car is beautiful you
guys always have extra accessories and
add-ons to the vehicles what are some of
the things that you guys offer thule has
a complete line of accessories rooftop
carriers bike racks kayak racks boogie
boards you name it they've got something
for every sport that you love burton
this is the perfect road trip car and
what i love about subaru is you guys
take care of your furry friends can we
talk pet safety absolutely you know
subaru loves pets let me show you
jc we've got great pet accessories pet
carriers pet beds and pet harnesses try
hooking that one up so this connects to
the headrest right here then you clip
this either onto your pet's harness or
the carrying case this is the ultimate
version of safety right here isn't that
awesome it's amazing well burton you've
got great cars and subaru you guys are
always giving back to las vegas what do
you guys have coming up we have some
awesome events happening this month from
michael's angel pause we are doing a dog
photo calendar contest from june 1st to
june 30th you can register on subaru of
las vegas.com post your photos of your
of your dog and hopefully you can win
and then finley's super las vegas dog
days of summer on saturday june 25th 10
a.m to 2 p.m the henderson animal care
and control bureau is doing a dog
adoption day and we are covering half of
the adoption fees on that day burton
that's awesome you guys here at subaru
you guys do everything
everything except pedicures
i need some work down there i need some
more thank you
thank you jc
we have a lot going on check out the
fill the boot fundraiser for uso nevada
at findlay subaru of las vegas for more
information call
702-495-2100 and they got a great
special offer 1.9 financing for
well-qualified buyers for up to 48
months on select 2022 models and then
registration fees are covered up to 200
on select pre-owned units